European Parliament president Antonio  Tajani will open a formal sitting of the  chamber to mark international Holocaust  Remembrance Day members vote on new  rules governing the dot EU domain name  changes include updating regulations for  an evolving online landscape and  relaxing rules on who can register a dot  EU domain the prime minister of Finland  juha sip Allah is the guest speaker at  this week's future of Europe debate  Parliament discusses changes to its  in-house rules the updated rules of  procedure will clearly outline the  rights and responsibilities of members  and demand more transparency from  parliamentary groups MEP s return to the  question of possible breaches of EU  values in Hungary in September 2018  parliament called on EU countries to  trigger sanctions over the erosion of  Rights and Freedoms  [Music]